I just got a missed call from myself
aren't you very bench check but it
wasn't really a call from the future you
but scammers taking advantage of number
substitution technology most fake calls
are made using the voice over Internet
Protocol blocking the number isn't going
to help you here you can't block the
scammers you can only block the number
itself which they choose to use for the
cool initially number substitution was
created for convenience for example so
that all employees of the same company
could call from the same number number
substitution is actually legal but the
fraudulent schemes that are pulled off
with its help are not so how can you
protect yourself from this threat don't
answer phone calls from unknown numbers
install an app that blocks spam calls
change your telephone number especially
if your number has been spoofed ask your
mobile operator for an unused number and
our final piece of advice subscribe to
our channel to find out more about
staying secure in the online jungle